Did you hear what the cow said to the
farmer on a cold winter morning?
Thanks for the warm hand
anyway.
It's going to get better,
so don't panic on the
start.
Small.
Nice to see all of you.
How many of you have never seen me
before?
Is this your first time?
Oh Wow.
Most of you.
Okay.
I keep thinking for sure.
I'm more famous than that,
but uh,
you know,
that is the truth.
I'm delighted to be here and looking
forward to it for a long time and it's
nice to be back.
You know,
I was here not too long ago.
It's nice to be invited back.
It says something when you're invited
back.
It doesn't say everything but says
something.
Maybe it says,
let's give him one more chance.
Right?
See if he can get it right this time.
But I'm delighted to have all of you
here.
We're going to spend the day together.
I feel two major responsibilities and
I'm sure you can guess what those are.
Number one is to make sure you get your
money's worth right when you shallow out
your cash,
basically these days you want to make
sure you get full value for the money
you spent,
and I know the tab for the seminar was
not that much.
Pretty modest fee to get in most of you,
your tips for the week,
right?
So it wasn't that much,
but I want you to be able to say,
when you walk out of here today,
it was worth my money,
but my biggest responsibility is to make
sure you get your time's worth.
And the reason I say that is because
time is more valuable than money.
In fact,
you might start your notes with that.
Time is more valuable than money.
You can get more money,
but unfortunately you can't get more
time.
If somebody asked you to spend your
money,
that's pretty easy,
right?
We live in America were wealthy,
so the money's not the problem,
but what if somebody asks you to spend
the day?
Right?
You got to think that over carefully,
and I know you did.
I wouldn't waste one of my days and not
for anybody,
not for anything.
Once I understood how valuable they
were,
I don't waste any,
but to make an investment like today of
your money and your time,
I appreciate it.
That today is going to be constantly for
me.
It's going to cost me one of my days to
be here
and some money of course,
but no,
I don't need the money.
I take the money,
but I don't.
I don't need the money,
but guess what?
I do need the time.
So I'm here not to just joke with you on
here,
not to just tell some funny stories and
give a performance and walk away.
I'm here to give you some value and I
want to make it worth your time.
I'm going to invest a day.
You're going to invest today.
Let's get the most out of it and see
what we can walk away with today.
Anyway,
for you that have not seen me before.
Just very briefly,
let me just tell you my story.
I grew up in Idaho farm country,
southwest corner of Idaho.
In fact,
my father still lives on the old
homestead where I grew up.
He'll be 89.
His next birthday still hasn't retired.
I'm proud of.
My Dad has never been ill.
He's really something.
I'm trying to get him to retire this
year.
80 eight.
I'm telling my father,
what a good year to retire when you're
88.
And he says,
Hey,
talk to me in 10 years.
Right.
I might be ready.
But anyway,
I went to high school.
I graduated,
I went to college one year.
Halfway through my second year of
college I decided I was smart enough.
So I quit.
One of my major mistakes.
I should've stayed in school.
Uh,
but I thought,
yeah,
you know,
I'm smart enough to get a job.
That's what life's all about,
right?
Get a job,
pay your bills,
were card and stay out of trouble.
Keep your fingers crossed and hope for
the best.
And I figured I was at least prepared to
do that.
So I quit college and went to work.
Then a while later,
got married,
got my little family going,
and I'm out there doing what I thought
was the best I could,
but at about age 25,
I'm starting to struggle.
I've purchased a little more than I can
conveniently pay for on time and the
creditors are starting to call saying,
hey,
you told us the check was in the mail.
What's the deal?
And I'm getting embarrassed by that.
I'm also embarrassed,
big mouth me with all the fancy promises
I made to get married.
I'm way behind on those promises and I'm
getting discouraged or wondering what to
do.
And I thought,
well maybe I should go back to school,
right?
One Year of college.
Pretty short on an application.
But uh,
you know,
tough to go back to school,
right.
Especially when you got your family
going.
Time to stay is when you're there.
Uh,
so I discounted that.
I thought,
well,
if I had my own business,
that would be the way to go.
But you know,
I'm short on money too much month at the
end of the money you've ever been there.
That's where I was age 25.
So I had to discount that and I'm
discouraged wondering where do I go from
here?
And then the miracle happened for me.
Good fortune came my way,
and who can explain good fortune?
I don't know,
remarkable things that happened to you
at a particular time.
Sometimes it's just unexplainable how
those things happened.
One of my friends says,
well,
hey,
things don't just happen.
Things happen.
Just another good note for your notes.
Things don't just happen.
Things happen.
Just.
And maybe that's it.
I don't know.
I'm an amateur on life,
I guess like most of us are trying to
figure it out,
how to make it valuable.
But I was ready and my good fortune was
at age 25.
I met a very wealthy man.
His name was Mr Shoaff,
Mr Earl show.
A friend of mine had gone to work for
him and he started telling me about this
man.
He said,
you got to meet this man I've gone to
work for.
He's wealthy,
but he's easy to talk to a and he's got
a unique philosophy of life.
And the more he kept talking about this
man,
I thought,
well,
I've got to meet this man.
So sure enough,
shortly after that I had a chance to
meet this remarkable wealthy man.
And I was impressed.
He was wealthy.
Sure enough,
he was easy to talk to.
I was so intrigued.
Within a few minutes,
I said to myself,
if I could be like him,
farm boy from Idaho,
I could be like him.
I'd give anything.
And then I thought if I could just get
around somebody like him and if he would
teach me what to do,
I would be willing to learn.
I'm coachable.
And that was my good fortune.
A few months later,
this wealthy man that I met,
Mr Joe took a liking to me,
hired me,
gave me a job.
I went to work for him and I spent the
next five years in his employer.
And then unfortunately he died at the
end of that period at age 49 his last
five years.
But the first five years of my new life,
I got to spend with this remarkable man.
And my dream came true.
He coached me and taught me.
He taught me the books to read.
He taught me the discipline.
He taught me the changes to make in my
language and personality and the things
he shared with me during that five
years,
literally changed my life,
turned my life around,
change my income,
changed my bank account.
That changed my future,
changed everything.
I've never been the same since that
unique experience and I wish he was
still alive today.
Mr. Show,
I'm sure if he was alive today,
especially after this seminar,
Idaho farm boy and mix it to Dallas,
fort worth,
full house,
standing room only.
Pretty awesome.
I'm sure he was alive.
I'd be calling him today saying,
you won't believe what's happening to
me.
I've had a chance now to share with
other people what you shared with me,
but anyway,
how I got here 30 plus years ago.
I was living in Beverly Hills,
California and one day a friend of mine,
businessmen friend said,
Jim,
would you,
I'd like to have you come and share your
story with my service club that I belong
to the Rotary Club.
He said,
I know your story.
Idaho farm boy and makes it to beverly
hills,
but he said,
I think my club members would love to
hear your story.
He said,
if I arranged one of our breakfast
meetings,
would you come and tell your story?
Just share a few thoughts.
And I said,
okay,
uh,
so I agreed to go give this breakfast
talk and guess what?
They liked it.
And my telephone rang.
I got another call.
I've got another call saying we heard a.
you've given your story and shared some
ideas.
Would you come talk to our club?
Tough dark club?
First thing I know I'm starting to
devote a piece of my business time to
giving these talks.
And then one day a businessman who had
heard my talk,
I think two or three times approached me
and said,
would you come and share that story and
some thoughts with my management and
sales?
And I got this little company going and
he said,
if you'd come and tell your story to my
organization,
he said I'd be happy to pay.
And I thought,
wow,
wouldn't that be something?
So I agreed to go do it and I got paid.
Little did I know another fortune was
waiting for me to translate my ideas
into talks and speeches and seminars.
Now I've written some books.
It's on cassette tape now I get to
travel around the world.
Last year I was in Japan is real Spain,
Mexico,
Australia,
New Zealand,
France,
Germany,
Canada,
and now Dallas,
fort worth,
Idaho farm boy gets to travel around the
world and sharing dory and here I am
today.
Anyway.
It's almost too much for me to
comprehend from where I started,
raised in obscurity,
a little small farm community and now to
be here.
Today's pretty awesome for me.
So anyway,
that's just a little bit about my story.
My story is probably more intriguing for
me than it is for you,
but I wanted to hear it again.
So I thought I would just bore you with
it anyway.
I don't ask you to be impressed today.
I'm the one that's impressed from where
I came from to have a chance,
but that's the American dream,
right?
Come true.
Chance to start from scratch.
Start from obscurity.
Start with pennies.
Start with nothing and have a chance to
transform your life,
change your life,
set your goals,
and see what you can accomplish.
So anyway,
that's how I got here and I'm just
delighted that this day has arrived and
I truly want to make it valuable for
you.
Let's go to work.
Here's what I hope you'll find out of
this seminar today for your notes.
Here's what I hope you'll find.
Number one,
sincerity
above all else today.
I hope you will find me sincere,
best place for people to start to
communicate his sincerity on both sides.
I'm sure you're sincere or you wouldn't
be here today,
right?
To spend this kind of money,
to spend this kind of time.
Roll up your sleeves today,
go to work like I am,
and get this message.
You've got to be sincere,
so I assume you're sincere.
Now,
I want you to see me sincere,
but I've got a good note for you to
make.
Sincerity is not a test of truth.
Important note,
to make sincerity is not a test
truth.
We must not make the mistake of saying
he must be right.
He's so sincere.
That would be a mistake,
and here's why it's possible to be
sincerely wrong,
so we don't mistake sincerity for truth,
right?
Sincerity is only a test of sincerity.
Truth has to yet be tested by truth.
Okay,
but hopefully you will find
me sincere and truthful.
Next,
a combination of things I hope you'll
find here today.
Ideas plus inspiration,
ideas,
plus inspiration
business ideas,
and social ideas and personal ideas.
We all need ideas,
right?
How to have a good day,
ideas,
how to have a good year,
how to have your best year ever.
Ideas,
good health ideas,
personal relationship ideas,
how to deal with your family ideas,
sales management ideas,
financial freedom for the future ideas.
We all need good ideas.
So today I hope you gather up by notes
and by what you can remember.
A lot of ideas.
I want to share as many with you as I
possibly can and the time constraints we
have today is going to go very rapidly.
I used to think a day like this was a
long day.
Found out it's pretty short day,
but I'm going to go as fast as I can,
share with you as many ideas as I
possibly can and here's why.
Ideas can be life changing.
Ideas can be life changing and sometimes
all you need is just one more in a
series of good ideas.
It's like dialing the numbers into the
lock,
right?
You got five or six numbers dialed into
the lock.
The lock still won't come open,
but you don't need five or six more
numbers.
Maybe you just need one more and maybe a
seminar like this could do.
A sermon,
could do it.
The lyric from a song could do it.
The dialogue from a movie,
you could do it conversation with a
friend might do it.
That one last piece,
you need number,
dial it into the lock.
That's it.
The lock comes open.
There's the door for you to walk through
and maybe this seminar today could
furnish that for you.
One more idea.
I know you've come with a lot already.
Sometimes we get the impression I used
to have that,
but I only had this much going for me
and I needed this much,
usually not true,
and I'm sure not true of this audience.
Where do I find you today as well
dressed as you look today.
You know,
it's fine as you are sitting here today.
It isn't that you know you've got this
much going for you and you need this
much.
I would assume you've got this much
going for you and maybe all you need is
just a few more thoughts,
ideas,
uh,
to furnish Houston ways and means to
turn your life into the dream you want
it to be.
So ideas.
The seminar is going to be loaded with
ideas.
I want you to take good notes,
but here's what else I hope you'll find
here today,
and that is inspiration
and who knows the mystery of
inspiration,
why some people are inspired and some
are not.
You weren't inspired to get here,
some were not.
Who knows the mystery of that?
I don't know.
How come you made it.
The rest of them didn't make it.
We don't know what that mystery is.
Some people turned it down,
some people said it costs too much.
Some people say it's going to take too
much time.
Some people are too busy,
right?
A lot of different excuses why some are
inspired to take advantage of something
that comes to town and pass it up.
We don't know the mystery to that.
Here's what I call it,
mysteries of the mind,
and I just leave it at that.
Some things I don't try to figure out.
I take the simple approach now,
right?
Some people do and some people don't.
I mean that's about as profound as my
philosophy is.
Some buyers and some don't buy something
go forward and some don't.
Some change and some don't.
And if you've been around for awhile,
you can usually work out the numbers
right out of 10,
you know,
three do $7,
whatever business you're involved in,
pretty soon you've got this ratio going.
The ones that do the ones that don't,
you say,
well,
why don't the ones that don't,
how come they don't?
We don't know.
I just leave it as a mystery.
I used to try to understand all that.
I just take the simple approach.
Now the guy says,
this happens to me.
This happened to me.
This goes wrong for me,
and all this stuff goes wrong for me.
How come all this stuff happens to me?
I say,
I don't know.
Beats me.
The Best I've been able to figure it out
is those kinds of things always happen
to people like you.
I mean,
that's the best I got.
I don't know.
I'm an amateur on this stuff.
What do I know?
So just take the simple approach,
right?
That's how it is.
Who knows?
Interesting story says the day the
Christian church was started.
Now I'm an amateur on the Bible,
but best account I can remember the day
the Christian church was started,
a magnificent sermon was preached,
great presentation,
and if you're a student of all at all,
have good communication.
It was one of the classic presentations
of all times the sermon.
The first day the Christian church was
started and it said the sermon.
This presentation was given to a
multitude,
meaning a lot of people,
but it was interesting as the account
gives us the record,
it says when the sermon was finished,
there was a variety of reaction to the
same server.
Isn't that fascinating?
I find it fascinating.
It said some that heard this
presentation were perplexed and I read
the presentation sounded pretty
straightforward to me.
He said,
why would somebody be perplexed with a
good,
sincere,
straightforward presentation?
Best Answer I've got.
They are the perplexed.
What other explanation is that?
It doesn't matter who's preaching.
It said some that heard this
presentation mocked and laughed,
made fun of the presentation.
I thought,
Hey,
this looks pretty sincere to me.
If you give a sincere,
honest presentation,
why would somebody mock and laugh?
Easy explanation.
They are the mockers and the laughers.
What else would you expect them to do?
I used to try to straighten all that
out.
Say,
well,
they shouldn't do that.
I don't do that anymore.
I've got peace of mind now.
I sleep like a baby.
Not try to straighten all this stuff
out.
I used to be so naive.
I used to say,
well,
liars shouldn't lie.
See how naive can you be?
Of course they're supposed to lie.
That's why we call them liars.
They lie.
Why don't straighten this stuff out
anymore.
Anyway,
it said some that heard this magnificent
presentation didn't know what was going
on,
and they're usually easy to spot.
They're usually saying,
what's going on,
right?
I mean,
they don't know what's going on,
but interesting,
right?
A variety of reaction to the same
sincere,
honest presentation.
Now it also says in wrapping it up,
some that heard the presentation
believed,
and I think that's who the speaker was
looking for.
The believers.
Interesting.
Now it said the number of believers was
about 3000,
so pretty good.
First Day,
3000.
I've had some first days though.
I never had 3000,
but anyway,
3000 were believers and that's the
speaker was looking for the believers
out of this multitude and that's about
as close as we can come to understanding
the mystery.
Some believe and some mock and some
laugh and some are perplexed and some
don't know what's going on and you just
have to leave it that way.
Why?
Because that's the way it's going to be.
The way to be brilliant is to find out
how it's going to be and then say,
here's how it should be.
I mean,
that's how you'd be coming.
Brilliant.
So anyway,
who knows the mystery,
I call it mysteries of the mind.
We don't understand,
but I don't try to change it anymore on
this particular story.
As far as we know,
they didn't have classes after the
presentation to try to deeper plex the
perplexed.
I mean as far as we know,
they left them for plaques.
They left the mockers mocking.
They let the laughers laugh.
I mean they didn't come back and try to
straighten all this out.
You say,
well,
how can you build a church?
Well,
make another presentation and you'll get
some believers and some mockers,
some laughers and some who don't know
what's going on.
So that's about the best we can do.
So.
But I'm glad I've got the believers here
today.
You believed enough to shell out your
cash and parked with your time and some
of your effort and energy,
and I appreciate that,
so hopefully you'll find some
inspiration here today.
All right,
to get the most out of today,
a couple of more notes.
Number one,
be thankful.
That's a good way to capture the most of
a day like this and be thankful for what
you already have.
That shouldn't be any problem in
America.
Being thankful.
Everything we need is available in
America.
Everybody wants to come here,
right?
The last time I was here,
that little presentation I gave,
everybody wants to come here.
America.
People haven't plotted and schemed the
last 40 years,
and if I could just get to Poland and
everything,
it'd be okay.
No,
everybody wants to come to America.
Why?
Everything's available here on the
books.
You need all the sermons you need,
all the churches you need all the
schools you need all the instruction.
You need all the inspiration you need,
all the capital you need,
all the markets you need,
all the challenge you need,
all the information you need,
all the seminars you need.
Everything's available here.
This is America,
so number one,
let's be thankful for what we already
have.
Thanksgiving does.
This,
opens up the doors,
opens up the windows,
opens up the channels,
thanksgiving for what you already have.
I did a seminar one weekend up at the
ranch up at clear lake,
got a lodge up there,
nice setting,
high valley high serenity ranch for the
weekend.
Friday evening,
Saturday,
Sunday.
People drove in from around California.
I got there late Friday afternoon.
Everybody had pretty well already gotten
there.
I couldn't believe the parking lot.
Continentals and Eldorados and Mercedes
and cadillacs and unbelievable Ferrari.
One Rolls Royce.
Unbelievable.
I walked in the crowd,
but like this,
sitting there ready for the weekend
seminar.
My opening remarks were ladies and
gentlemen,
I think the rest of the world would find
it strange that we have all come here
this weekend to try to figure out how to
do better.
I think the rest of the world would say,
I don't understand in his Rolls Royce
and I got to get to the seminar,
find out how to get another one of these
rolls royces.
Unbelievable.
Anyway,
let's be thankful.
Here's what locks up the doors and the
channels to receive more cynicism that
locks you away,
that prevents you from learning more.
Being a cynic about the past and the
future of cynic,
about the marketplace,
cynical about the people,
cynical about the institution since
cynical about the setup,
cynical about yourself,
cynical about your chances.
See that locks away all the chance for
stuff to flow your way.
So good advice.
I think today,
start off,
be thankful.
Here's number two.
Listen,
well,
that's gonna be a challenge today.
I understand.
That
seems like most of you know,
our life is still going on outside these
four walls,
right?
Most of our life seems like it's out.
Continuing out their family and business
associates,
market and economy and whatever else is
happening in the midst of your life and
to Sorta pull your attention from what's
going on out there and put it in here
for just a few hours.
I know is a challenge,
but do the best you can.
Listen.
Well,
here's the last one.
Take good notes.
Be a good student today.
Take some good notes.
I have not come to entertain you as you
can tell by my opening joke,
right?
I would not make it in Las Vegas so we
don't have a dog and pony show today.
No entertainment,
but I do have some ideas.
Take some good notes.
Somebody showed me the other day notes
that they took about 21 years ago,
attending one of my seminars out in Los
Angeles.
He said,
I still use these notes.
I took 21 years ago to help me in my
business relationship with my family,
so I'd like to have these notes that you
take today,
become that valuable for you than it
would be worth me making the investment
to come and spend a portion of my life.
My my energy here and I want this
investment I'm making here today to pay
off,
and one of the ways it can pay off for
me,
it's for you to take good notes and then
go away and use whatever makes sense
because what I feast on,
coming back around as the stories out of
this audience today.
Sure enough,
six weeks from now,
six months from now,
six years from now,
somebody is going to by phone,
by letter,
by personal contact.
Walk up to me and say,
the things you shared that day got me
thinking and I started making some
changes and let me tell you what's
happened to my business.
Let me tell you what's happened in my
sales career.
relationship with my family.
See that will make it worth it for me,
not the money,
the return.
Something you can't buy with money.
If somebody says,
thank you for touching my life and
taking the time to make the investment,
and that's what I'm all about.
So if you'll become a good student
today,
and here's the last note,
don't be a follower.
Be a student
you'd be happy to know today we haven't
come seeking disciples.
We've got no movement for you to join.
I'm just here to share some of my
experiences,
good ideas,
best I can,
but I think that's good advice.
Don't be a follower.
Be a student,
right?
Take advice,
but not orders.
Take information,
but don't let somebody order your life.
Make sure what you do is the product of
your own conclusion.
Excellent note to make.
Make sure what you do is the product of
your own conclusion.
Not to do what someone else says.
Take what someone else says,
process it,
think about it,
ponder it.
If it makes you wonder,
if it makes you think,
then it's valuable.
Then when you go take action,
make sure that the action is not what
somebody told you to do.
Make sure the action is the product of
your own conclusion.
If you will,
follow just a little bit of those simple
guidelines.
I'm telling you,
the learning process can be speedy,
swift,
powerful.
Your learning curve can go up and then
applying it to your business,
your life,
your family conversations,
equities of all kinds.
You'll find some progress like I did
that first five years when I met a
teacher willing to share with me,
turn my life around progress I couldn't
believe happened for me.
Okay,
let's get started.
I want to review.
I was here last time and we talked about
the five major pieces to the life puzzle
and I just want to review those because
it lays such a good foundation for all
the rest that I want to share with you
today.
We've got a lot of subjects to cover so
we're going to go rather swiftly.
Okay.
Put on your mental track shoes here and
run with me today because I'm going to
deal mostly in concepts.
Expect you to,
you know,
fill in a lot of the details because I
got a lot to share.
I want to get through it all but let's
lay this foundation again of the five
major pieces happens to be the title of
my latest book,
but I think it is so valuable and laying
a foundation at some of the things I
between ages 25 and 30,
the teacher who taught me taught me so
well.
He dealt in these fundamentals,
we call these fundamentals.
We call these basics
basics for sports,
fundamentals,
for sports,
for your business,
fundamentals for the way you deal with
your family.
A few simple things,
few basic things that if you practice
everyday can make all the difference in
the world.
How it works out.
I boiled it down to five major pieces to
the life puzzle.
Let's just review those.
Number one is philosophy.
Philosophy.
Philosophy is I taught the last time I
was here.
Philosophy in my personal opinion,
is the major determining factor in how
your life works out philosophy,
the major determining factor in how your
life works out philosophy to form our
philosophy.
You've got to think,
got to use your mind to process ideas
and this whole process over a lifetime
starting way back here when we were
children,
schools that we've attended,
our parents,
our experiences,
all this stuff that we've processed by
the thinking process helps to develop
our philosophy and in my opinion,
each person's personal philosophy is the
major factor in how your life works out.
Here's what I called it in that last
presentation when I was here.
It's called the set of the sail.
Each person's personal philosophy is
like the set of the sail now,
I used to think of was circumstances
that ordered my life.
If someone would have asked me at age
25,
Mr Owen,
how come you're not doing well?
Pennies in your pocket,
creditors calling nothing in the bank
behind on your promises to your family.
You live in America.
Twenty five years old,
got a beautiful family.
Every reason to do well and things are
not going that well for you.
What is wrong here?
It would not have occurred to me to
blame my philosophy.
I mean it would not have occurred to me
saying,
well,
I got this lousy philosophy and that's
how come I got pennies in my pocket and
nothing in the bank and things aren't
working well.
That would not have occurred to me.
I found it much easier to blame the
government.
Much easier to blame the tax problem.
I used to say taxes are too high.
Top tax rate.
When I first started paying taxes,
91 percent
back then when your income reached a
certain level,
all your income over that 91 percent,
so I have to say that's too high.
Now,
the tax top tax rates about 33 percent,
but people are still saying what taxes
are to see,
but you can't use that anymore.
If it's gone from 91 to 33,
how could it be?
Do.
Hi,
come on.
I threw all that old excuse stuff away.
Some people found it though and they're
using it these days.
My old list,
I used to blame the traffic.
Weather used to blame circumstances,
right?
People say I'm too tall.
I'm too short.
I'm too old.
I was raised in obscurity,
raised on a farm.
Parents of modest means all the stuff.
If you had asked me,
how come you find yourself here,
Mr Owens,
age 25,
living in America,
land of abundance and opportunity,
Kenny's zero in the bank,
not doing well.
Creditors calling.
It would not have occurred to me to
blame my philosophy.
I found it easier to blame the company
company policy.
I used to say,
if this is all they pay,
how do they expect you to do well?
So I figured that you know,
my future was going to be tied to what
everybody else was arranging the
economy,
right?
Interest rates.
I used to say things cost too much.
That was my whole explanation,
not my philosophy until my teacher
taught me better that this is where the
problem was.
My own personal philosophy.
Here's what's exciting about each
person's personal philosophy.
That's what makes us different than dogs
and animals and birds and cats and
spiders and alligators.
That's what makes us different than all
the life forms.
The ability to think,
the ability to use your mind,
the ability to process id is and not
just operate by instinct
in the winter and I'm telling you,
the goose can only fly south.
South doesn't look too good,
tough luck.
It can only fly south,
but see,
human beings are not like a goose can
only fly south.
I mean you can turn around and go north.
You can go east,
you can go west.
You can order the entire process of your
own life and we do that by the way.
We think we do that by exercising our
mind.
We do that by processing ideas and come
up with a better philosophy,
a better strategy for our life goals for
the future.
Okay.
Plans to achieve those goals.
All this comes from developing our
philosophy.
Philosophy helps us to process what's
available.
Well,
when we get here,
we got seed and we got soil and we got
some rain and we've got some hot
sunshine and we've got some seasons and
what the miracle of life.
Now the key is what do you do with all
this stuff?
How do you turn all this stuff that's
available here into equity and promise
and lifestyle and dreams and future
possibilities.
All of this that's possible now with
human beings.
How do you take all this stuff and turn
it into this equities and values?
Well,
it starts with philosophy.
What is the seed?
What is the soil?
It is the sunshine.
What is the rain?
Is it possible to take some of each of
all the stuff that's available and turn
it into food and turn it into value and
turn it into nourishment,
turn it into something spectacular and
unique that no other life form can do,
and the answer's yes,
but you cannot deal with all this stuff
and what to do with it unless you start
refining your philosophy.
Think use your mind,
come up with ideas and strengthen your
philosophy,
so the seed in the soil and the rain and
the sunshine.
This is called you know the economy and
the banks and the money and the schools
and everything that's available out
there,
processing information.
What to do with all that and turn it
into equity and value.
That is the major challenge of life.
My personal opinion,
so each person's personal philosophy now
is going to determine what you're going
to do with seed and soil and sunshine
and rain miracle,
the change of seasons.
That's it.
My personal opinion,
each person's personal philosophy is
like the set of the sail.
That's what the seminars for today help
you to trim a better sale.
You don't need a better economy,
you don't need better seed and soil.
In fact,
when it comes to seed and soil and rain
and sunshine and seasons and the miracle
of life,
that's all you got.
Now,
what if you blame this stuff?
Then you're blaming all you got.
If you blame the economy and you blame
the schools and you blame the teachers
and he blamed the sermons and the
preachers and,
and you blame,
uh,
you know the marketplace and you blame
the company and company policy.
What else is there?
When some people get through with their
blame list,
there is nothing else.
That's all there is.
And if you blame the only thing you've
got to work with,
I'm telling you,
it's called mistake,
colossal
and not understanding that that's all
you've got to work with.
And if this is all you've got to work
with,
then you don't change the seed and you
don't change the soil and you don't
change the rain and you don't change the
sun sign.
You don't change the seasons.
Right?
Guy Says,
I'll take three springs,
four summers,
nine falls,
no winters,
no,
you can't fool with this stuff.
You've got to take it like it comes.
Then what do you change to make your
life work?
Well,
you gotta start with your philosophy.
Guess what?
I had to do at age 25.
In order to change my own future,
I had to change my mind.
I had to change my thinking.
I had to change my philosophy.
I was messed up on what was causing my
problem and once I got that straightened
out that all the stuff I blamed the
government and taxes and the marketplace
and the economy and things cost too much
negative relatives,
cynical neighbors.
Once I got rid of that and started going
for where the real problem was,
which was me,
I'm telling you,
my life exploded into change.
My bank account changed immediately.
My income changed immediately.
My whole life took on a whole new look
and color immediately,
and the early results I got from making
philosophical changes tasted so good.
I've never stopped the process from that
day until this,
and I'm telling you with a little
consideration of the refinement of your
sale by setting a better sale,
refining your philosophy,
your whole life can start to change from
today on.
You don't have to wait till tomorrow.
You don't have to wait til next month.
You don't have to wait until spring.
Don't have to wait until 93.
You can start this whole process
immediately.
I recommend it now.
Some people do so little thinking they
don't even have their sale up.
I mean you can imagine where they're
going to wind up at the end of this
week,
at the end of this month,
at the end of this year.
Now is the chance to change process all
this information.
So number one is philosophy and we dealt
with all that.
Where are we?
Get ideas from personal experience,
from other people's experiences.
I don't want to get into all those
details because we've covered that.
The last time I was here philosophy.
That's number one,
my personal opinion,
each person's personal philosophy.
Here's the definition of success and
failure.
Just make this note.
Here's failure,
a few
errors in judgment
repeated every day.